i'm in a 12-step program in aaa right so
i was now you know
i'm in recovery so almost two years now
and that really changed my life getting
into you know 12 steps and
you know we'll you know and i know
that's your book um
but i one of the things that stuck with
me is esteemable people do esteemable
things
and it's like right and it's like when
you have that choice to do something
better than
alcohol man yeah yeah the funny thing is
if you're trying to stop drinking you
need something better than alcohol and
alcohol is pretty good
yeah so you better find something a lot
better man yeah
and it is then esteemable people do
esteemable things it's like yeah well
you want to figure out
you want to figure out something that
you're doing with your life that's worth
not getting drunk and screwing up yeah
right
because that's fun yeah you want to have
something on the other side of that
teeter-totter that has uh some value
you bet you bet and so that you can
think no no i'm not going to get drunk
and screw that up
right because you know you might say
well why do people drink too much it's
like if you like alcohol that's a stupid
question
yeah right it's like why do people drink
too much well because it's great
you know it's like okay so why stop well
you do stupid things when you're drunk
you hurt yourself you compromise your
health it's really hard on the people
around you you tend to turn into a liar
and it screws up your life
yeah it's like yeah but it's pretty fun
yeah well it is but
you need something better than that and
what's better isn't
being straight and and and not making
mistakes it's like that's all
prohibition in some sense what's better
is
no you need an adventure man you need to
get out there and have something to do
yeah and and something worth waking up
for and you need that's the substitute
for the addiction
actually the addiction is the substitute
for that if truth be known
right but eventually you can flip that
around and you can find that you know
the
the much girthier and and more
uh there's a lot of sexy weight and
having self-worth
you know and that's what i've started to
solely find in my life yeah and you
might also like the thing too is you
know i mean there's something kind of
i don't know the the bar scene that the
the heavy drinking scene there's
something kind of edgy about it you know
and something kind of adventurous about
it and
you know you see that it's kind of
dramatized in people like tom waits
who's got that real hard edge or johnny
cash or people
hard-living guys oh yeah six or seven
livers in them yeah yeah exactly
yeah well there's something kind of
romantic about that yes and and fair
enough you know but
well then what that means is you have to
build something like that into your own
life
so maybe you need to go maybe you need
to you know take an adventurous trip now
and then you got to have something there
that
that that's that's edgy to replace that
and sometimes if people need a catalyst
so there's that moment right
like for me the catalyst was like um
you know i needed to probably i was
experimenting with cocaine and i
sacrificed like a
a neat job opportunity with that i had
planned on being there for the job
and next thing you know i spent the
night doing cocaine right so i realized
okay this is not
this is a little out of my control so i
have to make this but if if people don't
have that sort of
i'm sure this must have happened when
you decided to stop drinking you must
have thought
this isn't good i'm not going to be
funny anymore i thought that i thought
i thought there was going to be
ramifications yeah okay and so what were
they what what
what did you what did you foresee
happening i thought i wouldn't be funny
i thought that people wouldn't like me
i thought that um i wouldn't be able to
meet girls if i wasn't drinking or
or you know or having drugs or um
right so that was what you were afraid
of giving up if you stopped drinking
right what were you afraid of happening
if you kept drinking
um i was afraid of not
achieving my dreams i was afraid of you
know uh
ending up a drug addict yeah of dying in
my sleep something you know dying under
the influence okay so there so
yeah it's not like that doesn't happen
to comedians right it happens a lot yes
it's one of our goats well exactly well
it's not an occupational hazard because
you're up late at night you're around
bars all the time
it is because you're up late at night
and yeah
right here right right well and it
happened to all sorts of comedians and
rock musicians usually happens in about
you know weirdly enough so okay so you
were afraid you're afraid you're going
to die or you're afraid you're going to
become addicted so so let's say what
what of life what would have life like
being like you for for you if you were
addicted so you don't have a career
anymore
no right so you've given all that up and
failed so that's fun
so that's going to drive you even more
towards drugs yeah it would have been
all my dreams it would have been
miserable right it would have been hell
exactly is that so why quit drinking
so i don't end up in hell hey there's a
reason there's a reason to stop and then
if you make that hell real
it's like here's all the details of my
personal hell
yes let's avoid that right so then you
have something to run the hell away from
right so now you have something towards
and something to run away from and i'll
say this too
as you for if there's any young men or
women out there who are listening to
jordan feeling like
well i still i don't know if you know if
i start doing something different like
my friends are going to have to start
yeah they are they are yeah but you're
also you're going to
start creating conversations you're
going to become
the intrigue because you're going to be
bringing something new to the table
you're also going to find out who your
friends are yeah because if you're
starting to put your life together
and you have friends that object those
are not friends
those are just people you know they're
not friends because
a friend is someone this is one of the
hallmarks of a friend here's two
hallmarks
a friend is someone you can tell bad
news to and they won't tell you why
you're an idiot and
they won't interfere with your suffering
they'll just listen and maybe they'll
suffer along with you
okay so you can tell bad news to them
and they won't tell you some worst thing
that happened to them
they'll listen they'll suffer along with
you but a friend is also someone you can
tell good news to
and the friend will say wow in this veil
of tears
something good happened to you great man
i'm wonderful
it's rare it's unlikely good for you i
hope 10 more things like that happen and
they're not envious and they're not
jealous and they're not one up in you
and if you're trying to get your life
together it's actually if you're trying
to get your life together
and your friends get in the way that's
actually real useful for you because
you've now identified who your friends
aren't
and you might think well i can't give
them up it's like oh yes you can and not
only
can you you should and it would be
better for them
because if they're aiming down and they
want you going down with them
there's nothing good about what's
happening to them and there's certainly
nothing good about that for you yeah
they're not gonna and then they're gonna
learn wow if i
i'm gonna lose friends if i continue in
these directions yeah exactly
exactly is it hard for why is it hard
for people to let go of what's so
familiar with to them
even if it's bad well because it's
complicated
you know and the thing that's a really
good question you discount the risk of
familiarity
that they're familiar with so like let's
say because people are in relationships
people are in relationships with the
drugs and alcohol people in
relationships with humans people are in
relationships with jobs people in
relationships with their own selves
and they deliver they're they're living
a lie every single day but it's
it's familiarity yeah well you say i
have a job i hate
it's like well yeah but i'm not dying
from it's like not as bad as it can be
so
you kind of you kind of you factored in
the risks already they get invisible
you think well i can't jump out of this
job because what about all the risk
it's like yeah no kidding you got to
make a you got to get your resume in
order
you got to send it out you got to send
50 of the damn things out before anybody
will call you back
then you have to go get interviewed and
maybe you're not any good at that you
have to come up with a story while
you're a good employee and maybe
and maybe you're not yet so you have to
figure out how to do that it's like what
about all these risks if i go look for a
new job it's like yeah absolutely man
those are risks and they're harsh and no
wonder you're avoiding them
what about the risks for you to stay
with this job you absolutely hate
well let's think that through okay so i
have this dead end job i hate it i'm
getting better
where am i going to be in five years i
know where because i've watched this
with people
you're going to be you're going to be
just like you are now except a lot more
of what's good about you is going to be
gone
and a lot more of what's terrible is
going to be amplified and you're going
to be like
in five years you're going to be 10
years older instead of three years older
yeah right because it kills your spirit
yeah so it's like
you think oh my god there's a terrible
risk in pursuing this new job it's like
yeah there is a terrible risk
there's a terrible risk and you stand
with your job right now and so one of
the things that's really
really freeing to understand is that
you're screwed no matter what you do ah
there's no secure path forward
give it up it's risk everywhere oh my
god that's terrible it's like yes except
for two things
you can pick your risk that's the first
thing so you get to pick your poison
that's something and second you're a lot
tougher than you think
so even though there's risk everywhere
if you confront it
forthrightly what you'll find is that
you can actually handle the risk
and that's the security that's beautiful
and there's so much growth to be had
right there when you realize how much
like there were times i was like man i
could never be a sober person
because i'm afraid of you know i can't
communicate with women or i'm afraid to
you know stand around in a circle with
tough guys without having like a beer in
my hand you know or like
all these little crutches you know i
can't and then
i remember when i got like 90 days sober
i was just like holy man like
it was like the first time i'd ever done
something uh
like for myself you know yeah and it
just
man it felt it felt unprecedented yeah
yeah well it was
like i felt like i'd gone to the moon
how old were you when you started
drinking
uh i don't probably like 17 or 16 you
know kind of regular
yeah it was pretty basic and i never did
a bunch of it you know
but my biggest thing was just emotional
sobriety like i was so
drunk on my own insecurities and low
self-worth well alcohol
alcohol really is a good drug for coping
with anxiety that's why people use it so
it does too if you if you really like
alcohol it does
it does two things to you it makes you
more extroverted and enthusiastic
well you're on the ascending limb of the
blood alcohol curve which is why you
have to keep drinking
once you start because if you plateau
that goes away so you got to keep
drinking okay so that's one thing it
makes you more enthusiastic and
and more full of positive emotion and
the second thing it does is reduce
anxiety yeah and so if you are a bit
more socially anxious
and you also have that positive response
to alcohol which everyone doesn't have
by the way
then it's a great drug but the problem
is it's well
it's a great drug for the moment right
right there's
there's consequences yeah this sounds
when it's not great well it also
alcohol is an interesting drug because
it it it actually doesn't make people
stupid this is being tested like alcohol
people who are drunk will take far more
risk and you might say well that's
because they're too stupid to understand
the risk it's like no they're not
if you ask them about the risk when
they're drunk they can outline it
perfectly
what it stops them from doing is caring
about the risk it's actually
and that's part of the anti-anxiety
components like yeah the risk is that's
why you can drive around
drunk at high speed in a car which is
really stupid thing to do yeah
we used to do that in the back roads in
northern alberta it's fun
yeah you know but but people died all
the time doing it especially in the
winter it's like wow this is great it's
great until your head's gone through the
windshield you know like so many things
yeah it's like jumping off a cliff it's
i'm flying which is true until the last
one tenth of a second it's like then
you're not flying man
it's like yeah yeah so so alcohol
alcohol has exactly that effect it is a
great
anti-anxiety drug but it does stop you
and he said it stopped you from learning
the skills that you need in the social
circumstance to be able to cope with
that
so then it actually stops you from
dealing with the anxiety you don't have
to learn
how to overcome it that's not good yeah
so yeah
yeah you're not really learning you're
kind of just staying in the
you're just you're baiting the egg
you're you're kind of meeting the
anxiety with a little bit of light
medication but you're never
getting through whatever the anxiety was
yeah you don't know you don't have to
learn the skills well you said you like
to stand there with a beer in your hand
we'll give you something to do you
didn't know what else to do
then you didn't have to learn right i
had the same issue like i started
drinking when i was
13 probably yeah and and that's late in
canada
yeah that's right i mean i was way
behind my neighbors
they were slugging it back when they
were four oh i've been in edmonton and
i've seen people i mean it's just
people love to drink up there it's just
it's a fun culture right
it's a cultural thing on the farther
north you go the more the drinking
becomes necessary especially in the
winter you know so and there's not that
much to do in those isolated small towns
yeah i drink i'd drink my own blood
probably yeah well that's
it well that's funny when i used to go
back to the little town i was from when
i was an adult even if i hadn't had
nobody had anything to drink for years
it was like well what are we going to do
well let's go to the bar why well
because there actually isn't anything
else to do
so you know and so you end up there but
but but the
the alcohol is it's it's well it's a
hell of a it's a hell of a drug man
do you think watch it do you think it's
going to start get out to get outdated i
start to think that alcohol is almost a
drug of the past
slowly like i could see us like with
psychedelics and stuff like that
becoming a little bit more in like the
common sphere of conversation um well
it'd be interesting to see that we just
legalized marijuana in canada
yeah yeah like it's not it's not
completely legal yet but the bill was
passed
so canada is doing this country-wide
experiment and i know there is some data
showing that
in counties in the u.s where marijuana
has been legalized the overuse of
of opiates for pain has decreased
substantially and the crime rates have
gone down interesting well
still people stoned on pot it's hard to
pick somebody's pocket
yeah break into a building i don't think
so
you're just not going to get it together
you might knock for a long time
i think you might knock at the front
door i don't think you're gonna break in
and you're not gonna
you might that's right you might knock
you're not gonna go out what are you
gonna go in the alley and have a fight
no you're not a real slow fight
well while you're watching your hands
like yeah it's like chest with your
hands exactly
exactly that's not going to happen so
yeah who knows like i mean if we had to
make
a bad drug legal the worst choice was
alcohol
that's definitely the case you know and
i'm saying that as somewhat of a fan of
alcohol
me too yeah i like it it's but it's a
bad drug and is it also starting to
become archaic as we get into drugs that
are
you know like uh you know people are
using psychedelics more where people are
a little bit curious about drugs that
make you
think um instead instead of drugs that
make you not think
right yeah right yeah yeah because
alcohol is kind of an escape into
well it's not full unconsciousness
although it certainly can be
yeah but yeah and alcohol also makes
people aggressive it's the only drug we
know that actually makes people
aggressive
so and so so you see a massive effect on
crime rates because
half the people who murder someone are
drunk oh yeah and half the people who
are murdered are drunk
and you know and you're most likely to
be murdered by a family member so i've
been joking with my audiences is like
well if you really want to get killed
the best thing to do is go drink with a
family member
which is actually statistically true
which is terribly terribly
comical it's like yeah go get drunk with
your family if you want to die
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah